we have some breaking news this morning
because the second round of rescue
operations in Thailand is working to
save more members of a youth soccer team
and their coach they've been trapped in
a cave since June 23rd now one boy was
taken from the cave this morning and he
is at the hospital a 6th and 7th person
were just taken out on stretchers and
are about to be transported to the
hospital the first four boys were
rescued yesterday the local governor
says there are concerns about more rain
and flooding Ben Tracy is in chiang rai
thailand with the urgent push to rescue
the boys the clock is ticking Ben good
morning good morning it sure is and you
know it's been surprisingly dry here
today there's so they're certainly
trying to seize the moment get as many
of these boys out of this cave as
possible before it potentially floods
again so the second phase of this rescue
operation appears to be going very well
it appears also to be going very quickly
now while the divers are inside the cave
guiding these Boyd's boys to safety they
are still pumping water out to make sure
that that journey is as safe as possible
despite some heavy rain last night
officials say water levels inside the
cave did not rise much particularly
helping this effort it's speeding it up
now if the cave were to flood the
remaining boys could be stuck on a piece
of land that is only about 100 square
feet that concern is part of what
prompted the risky rescue operation to
begin now to get out of the cave each
boy is tethered to a diver who is
following a rope with another diver
trailing behind the two and a half mile
journey takes about takes several hours
as many as eight hours one of the most
difficult areas is a pinch point that is
just 15 inches across where the boys
have to separate from their diver to fit
through now officials here are telling
us that the entire rescue operation to
get everybody out of that cave could
take another 24 to 48 hours but they are
clearly ahead of schedule and it is very
good news here today to see so many of
these boys coming out of this cave gale
it is Ben Tracy it's great great great
news and we are all waiting and hoping
and praying it continues thanks a lot